I've heard you talk about moving out of
Baton Rouge and um you know I know that
you know you had instances with like the
the district attorneys there and stuff
trying to attach charges to you and
right you know there was a lot of what
seemed like from what I've heard
uncomfortableness between you and the
law enforcement there right maybe not
exactly they're cops but the over the
overseers of them um what is it about
Atlanta that is makes life more
comfortable do you think
Atlanta is big supersized you know I
don't stick out like a sore thumb yeah
yeah 20 superstars you know you got any
better
yeah they had you they had c-murder
Silkk the Shocker Master P and they had
that tiger that's in the cage outside of
the P max Center right right and most of
them from the wall yeah Baton Rouge is
different from New Orleans Baton Rouge
is you know Birmingham to Atlanta yeah
yeah you know as far as racism as far as
everything you know as the deep south
right so uh and Atlanta is different
though and Atlanta is different you know
it's black power
ya know I did I was on stage there a
couple months ago I said damn it seemed
like Black History Month started a city
yeah that's what it seemed like
Yeah right is this black power well you
know black people own thing black people
have well you see if we have wealth you
see a lot of black policeman you see a
lot of you know and and the police
showed me love man it's crazy man it's
like it's like they want to help you you
know I can't say that for everybody in
Atlanta right but as far as the officers
I didn't ran into they want to see me
prosper man right I was in my Rolls
Royce one day I'm slipping I'm at the
light I'm smoking I'm high [ __ ] I'm
slipping
man I look to the side clear windows
Coley's looking at me he say
[ __ ] you telling me to roll out a
window
[ __ ] hey I know if he telling me to roll
down the wind and not pull off right I
got it
right right you say roll down the window
what up man man put that [ __ ] out man
going here man nobody told me put the
[ __ ] out Manny going here man take care
of your damn fan smoking weed out here
like this
man this [ __ ] was like man my heart just
dropped
yeah so that was you know they always
see me and be like they just give it up
to me bro and there's more understanding
they understand bro they understand that
you know I'm not even come to this city
to be a problem they understand that I'm
a businessman right you know and wealth
to changes things man I noticed even
just growing up in like we would go to
Atlanta sometimes to see the Sugar Bowl
or to visit an aunt that I had that
lived there occasionally we would drive
up to Atlanta and it's a for me just as
a you know me just a regular white
person pretty much but it was the first
city that I saw that had like black
wealth in it you know like in like a lot
of I'm talking a lot of money like the
car will pull up to a place and you'd be
like damn and black people would get out
I'd be like what the [ __ ] yeah you know
it was just it was different it was
something that you know I grew up in a
small town it was black and half black
half white but and we didn't have any
wealth bus but you had just never seen
that before you know like when I was
growing up the only wealthy black
Americans that I knew were like Dallas
Cowboys you know what I'm saying like
there was a couple people but you didn't
see it you never saw it in your face I
don't feel like until Atlanta right
right right they they set a stage for a
lot of [ __ ] cuz I'll because when I went
down and uh I'm a season ticket holder
on the beat so uh you know I've been
going in ba games and many and uh the
first time I saw you know with a
triple-a floor seats you know 70 percent
black you know you know and that made me
smile you know yeah you know black black
black black women you know successful
you know and we're nice big boys season
that and that's a change of culture yeah
you know it's not like that Louisiana
you know it's not like yeah you know
it's not like that other places is you
know
the stuff I see with the black people
out here me it makes me it makes me
proud you're hard to be blood
yeah yeah I can imagine it's totally
different I mean I'll just have my own
perspective but there is something
that's it's exciting to see when you see
oh if this culture has money they can
have a comfortable existence right right
right
and I don't mean that have any judgment
I just mean right I feel what you're
saying but uh I feel what you're saying
they got a ghetto everywhere they got a
ghetto everywhere slums everywhere yeah
it's just when more people show show
value and wealth it makes other people
want wealth and that cuts out the
[ __ ] right you know I'm saying
you mean like it inspires younger people
hires it inspires people yeah because
everybody has a role model yeah and the
role model is Daman ones with the most
money so uh you know is more role models
oh yeah I think like definitely more
more role models in Atlanta than a lot
of places you know yes especially for I
think for black kids you know I mean
just cuz like even if you think like you
know when I was growing up just like you
would see people come to the school and
they would say okay it's gonna be career
day at school somebody's dad's gonna
talk about their career and it was
always used like if it was a doctor it
was a white dot you know what I'm saying
like if it was right but now I think
especially in places like Atlanta you
have that it's different you know like
people come in it's all types of people
come and have a career and that gives a
kid sitting there like oh I can have
this right it gives them a different
aspiration good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one